fresh office 16th NBA draft covering it
for the worldwide leader in sports
ESPN's Jay Bilas here on the Rich Eisen
show how you doing Jay I'm doing great
rich how are you what do you think the
story last night was well I mean the
story going in were the big guys and how
many of them there were at the top of
the draft but I think you know after
watching it last night you know there
were bunch of good players in it I wish
I could say who I think we're gonna be
the best maybe you have beliefs but you
know I thought at the end of the end of
the night I was really interested in the
guards and and this is a 3-point
shooting spread floor game and the
longer droughts were the more I was
thinking you know look at Don judge made
a pretty good case to go number one
overall in today's game and in same
thing with us I don't say number one but
like Trey young and Collin Sexton and
Shaye Gill just Alexander you know some
of those guys that are their guards may
have bigger impacts than the big guys
even though the big guys can they can
all run they're all mobile they can all
step away they're not the the old school
sort of back to the basket anchor low
post guys but but I still think the
cards are gonna wind up have a pretty
big impact of this play
ya know it's so difficult obviously to
say for instance two years ago of you
know walking off the NFL Draft said hey
who's gonna start week one nobody would
have said Carson Wentz nobody in the
same way the last year who's gonna be
the best yo-yo Donovan Mitchell is gonna
be the best what do you think about fits
though who do you think was drafted in
like you know what the system they run
and the players that they have around
him this kid has a chance to really have
a great rookie campaign Jake no I didn't
see anybody that stood out that way rich
as far as because I think you're right
like I wouldn't have said last year when
Donovan Mitchell was taken 13th well
there's a guy who's gonna start and
he'll be he'll be a Rookie of the Year
candidate
I just didn't view him that way I didn't
think he'd be able to shoot it that well
all year long and then take over but I
will tell you this I mean I went to
college with what Snider routine Mason
College we've been friends for 30 years
and after the draft last year
I got a text from him saying woody what
do you think of Mitchell and I think
he's really good I think you guys got a
good player and if I remember right he
texted back something to the effect of
we think he can be like Russell
Westbrook and I was like what really
like why didn't you tell me that that
would have been nice to know before the
graph you know but I know why why they
didn't because they didn't want to let
out how much they liked it but you know
they're right and and there are there
may be gems in this draft that they're
College sort of college performances
didn't show cuz no it's no way did
Donovan Mitchell's college performance
show he was gonna make that kind of jump
and then other guys like that's one of
the things that kind of makes me laugh
like you and I are both a lot older than
when we first met but what I you
mentioned I was doing I've been doing
the 16 years the draft for 16 years and
when I first started doing this man I
was so secure in my convictions about a
player I may have been wrong but I was
like I I believed it down to my socks
now I'm looking at it God well maybe you
know like here's what I think but you
know I don't know I wanted to have I
wind up for like edging on everything
because I know like we just don't know
and I don't think they know in football
either I don't believe they do I think
you have belief sets but you know a lot
of really smart basketball people looked
at Steph Curry when he came out said
yeah he's gonna struggle I don't see him
translating as well and now that that
curry did so well now we're looking at
Trey young going yep he's Steph Curry
and I'm not sure it's that simple
well I'm imagining Jay that you don't
have to text Quin Snyder but what he
thinks about Grayson Allen and I'm
wondering what that pre-draft
conversation between Snyder and coach
Kay if there even was one if it was even
necessary you think about it I don't I
don't think it was all that necessary
you know Grayson Allen has has put
together a body of work and he look he's
a really good player and and nobody sits
on the fence with regard to him they
either like him or they don't and it has
nothing to do with how he plays it has
to do with whether they like him or not
so there's a lot of baggage they carry
it gets carried into this by fans
but what is undeniable is that kid can
really shoot it he came out of an MBA
work out recently that for a bunch of
different MBA teams and that was all MBA
personnel were talking about it's one of
the best shooting workouts they've seen
and so you know he's a he's a good
athlete he tested really well at the
combine
you know he's mature he's been he's been
knocked around a little bit so he's not
you know it's not like it's gonna be a
horrible adversity for him to go in the
NBA he's going in as a grown man kind of
old school that way like you know when
everybody used to go and when they were
22 and nobody said they'd hit their
ceiling yet right but but he'll do fine
there that's a good fit for him and he
can he can space the floor for them and
it makes shots if he doesn't have to
carry a big load he could just blend in
well speaking of grown men or guys who
had grown man performances at the
collegiate level in the last year or two
the big ragu Dante D Vincenzo going to
the Bucks how do you how do you like
that fit Jay Bilas I think Dante's gonna
do well I you know he's 21 years old he
was a redshirt because he was injured
his freshman year after came out of
Delaware and and he's he's exceeded my
expectations of him as a player and I
think he's going to continue to get
better you know do I think he's better
than some of these other guys in the
draft you know some of the other guards
I don't I think he was drafted about
where he should have been but you know
two three months ago I wouldn't have
said he was a first-round draft pick I
didn't I didn't see him that way but the
way he ended the season you know I it's
very rare you see a rise like that just
off of not only a championship but a guy
who who performs really well in the
n-c-double-a tournament and and look
he's legit he played really well at the
combine and showed what he's capable of
but I don't think he was a first-round
pick before that combine and when he got
out of there he was and and I think
he'll do well but I do think it's gonna
take him a little bit of time to figure
it out Jay Bell is here on the rich
Johnson show asking the poll question
Chris best weekend yeah Jay looking at
the top five which of these rookies
makes an all-star game first down
Drayton
from Bagley Lucca jaren Jackson or Trey
young I think it's going to be Luca da
judge because he's he's played more
high-level basketballs than anybody else
in this draft and in played in the
second best league in the world really
is the ACB League and I think he's he's
legit and I think he's going to do
really well it's just a question of how
well well is he given like he's not
going to be one of these like I think a
lot of people and then myself included
you know the first thing you think of
when you think of a European players
well look what applet sarcone remember
remember because excuse really well
there was no data on these guys just
summoned workouts maybe a little bit of
five on five you got years of tape on on
Luca Tanja to seeing them in person
they've scouted him more than any
college player in this draft and the
only thing he doesn't have is like crazy
world-class athleticism he's a really
good athlete but he's not a world-class
athlete like some of these other guys in
the draft and but he knows how to play
man but that dude can pass it he's he
can make shots he's unafraid and and you
know like I always write down the
scouting report says it makes it really
easy for me when I see a guy that said
that just man that guy knows how to play
he's got a field he's instinctive all
this stuff I just write down four
letters K k HT P and that's what I wrote
down when when I was watching tape of
this guy he just knows how to play and
he's gonna be fine a plane in Dallas
will really help because it's a little
more high-profile if he was in
Sacramento or something like that I
might not I might not have answered that
he'd be he'd be the first play in the
all-star head well and then that said
Jay a lot of folks thought the guy with
the most talent the highest ceiling to
use the talent evaluation phrase was
Michael Porter Jr if it wasn't for his
medical now that we know where he wound
up right in the middle of the first
round for the Nuggets do you think it
was proper that he fell as far as he did
would you have been on on that board if
you were an evaluator last night Jay it
depends like I haven't seen the medical
and it
two things on this one you know at some
point is the risk becomes worth it but
but if the medicals bad enough that you
don't think the guy's going to be
productive and he's not even worth the
14th pick but but to be able to get a
guy of that talent if you think that
he's going to be healthy to get that
kind of talent at 14 is a steal
if healthy in the long run now if he's
just gonna miss a year like you're like
Joelle and beat when he came out you
know I would look at it kind of like
with them beat if you could draft them
beat now and get after his freshman year
but you couldn't get him til after he
was junior I dropped him in a heartbeat
and I'd wait that time out but but if
you're talking about long-term injuries
that's a different deal well tell you
what I think what I can't believe
happens in the NBA is that that players
will give their medical to some teams
and not to others and I find that like
almost in unconscionable at the end the
NBA would allow that and you know look I
understand that that players the college
players and all that they are not
members of the Union until they're
drafted until they signed contracts so
you know you can't make them do it under
collective bargaining agreement but the
leak can tell every team once you get a
medical you got to share it with the
rest of the league like I don't think
the leaks teams should be competing on
on medical information that shouldn't be
some sort of competitive advantage that
the decision should be all right we've
all seen the medical you know rich your
team has more of a risk tolerance so
you're gonna take Porter at seven we're
we don't have that but that's what you
should be making your decision on not
not you know you haven't seen the
medical and I've seen all his x-rays
I've had all my doctors check it out
so I know something you don't on a
fundamental matter in a multi-million
dollar decision I can't believe the
legal aoz that I think the NFL does have
what you're talking about Jay at the NFL
count Ciano combine that it that's
everybody knows whether a kid has a
heart murmur everybody knows about
everything about a kid's medical going
into a draft I
yeah 100% sure ting on that Jay yeah
that just that just seems like you know
if the NVA were buying cars you know
they wouldn't just let one team look
under the hood you know the if the if
the owner let one team look under the
hood and everybody else has to look at
it the outside they you know that would
be right and and same kind of thing I
don't want to I don't want to make these
guys seem like they're machines or
anything but they are they are assets
and their assets these teams are poured
a lot of money in and I just don't see
how how some teams have you know didn't
know what Jaron Jackson's medical was or
didn't know what Michel Porter's medical
was that that doesn't seem right to me
last one for you Jay were you and Rhys
and the rest of the crew aware of Adrian
were janowski's uh thesaurus and synonym
for aid last night on Twitter not until
after I was not not aware until after
and and I couldn't stop laughing I mean
I just i won I love whoa I mean he's not
only a great guy and and just a pleasure
to be around but he knows everything I
mean literally everything that's going
on in the NBA and and when I found out
about it when Van Pelt was teasing them
about that one easy point he went on SBP
after the after the draft and then I
went read all read all of it and I
thought it was brilliant I absolutely
loved it I mean his English teacher no
doubt was beaming wherever that person
oh yeah that's not the double negatives
it was fantastic and as best you can
tell the ESPN they end of NBA didn't say
anything about it during the uh during
the broadcast I guess I don't know I
didn't really know about I I read about
it this morning so I didn't know about
you know hope that the prohibition or
all that stuff that's what I was just
worried about how many times I was gonna
say wingspan and you know just tonight
did I get away you know can I get away
with like how am I gonna how am I gonna
talk about this guy be it really good on
ticket rolls well the next guy is really
good I pick and rolls this guy's really
here get out how do you avoid saying the
same thing over and over gonna head my
plate full well you need to go to woge
and get some synonyms for that next year
maybe you know get look at is that
source that's a good idea I got it I got
a plan better
Jay great chat as always will talk down
the line thanks for the time today
brother
appreciate great beer already broke
otherwise that's Jay Bilas the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience